lorsque quand tu as pas l'immera votre
réseau vous pourrez pour le même prix
regarder la télévision par Internet et
avoir un débit 100 fois plus rapide mais
depuis 2009 et la création de cette
régie de réseau le très haut débit à 50
ans en Yvelines est un parcours du
combattant les opérateurs soucieux de
leur monopole ne reconnaissent pas quand
tu hop un déni bien aidé par le mutisme
de l'État face aux nombreux appels de
l'entreprise résultat la Régie a du
suspendre à l’été 2012 le déploiement du
réseau habitants pour sortir de
l'impasse Quantium vient de porter
plainte auprès de la Commission
européenne le but obtenir la
confirmation de l'égalité de statut
entre opérateurs privés comme SFR Orange
Bouygues et régie autonome le paradoxe
et qu'on se retrouve dans une situation
où on est en capacité déployée les
investissements sont calibrés le
financement est identifié et ce mutisme
national fait que la situation est
complètement bloquée donc il faut en
faut là il faut la débloquer espérons
que l'État va se rendre compte qu'il y a
vraiment une porte de sortie qui a
vraiment quelque chose à faire ce
déploiement de la fibre optique sur
l'agglomération coûterait entre 25 et 30
millions d'euros si le recours de
quantiope devant la Commission
européenne n'aboutit pas l'ensemble de
la population 50-hinoise devra
probablement attendre 2019 pour recevoir
le très haut débit